I have with me rappin suck an egg roffle
tell us about the major significant
developments in broadband over the last
few years things are really happening in
Poland don't like Poland is one of the
biggest telecommunication market in
Europe the value of it is over 9 billion
euro there is a lot of potential in this
market almost fifty percent of
households are in the range of
infrastructure capable of delivering
internet above 30 megabits per second
but on the other side there is a still
huge problem with access to the
broadband in rural areas that's why we
addressed to this to this the twist
matter to this problem funds under EU
budgetary 2007 2013 it is over 1 billion
euro dedicated for network
for deployment of broadband networks
especially in rural areas by the end of
2015 we are going to build to finalize
58 thousand kilometers of broadband
mostly of them it will be mostly of them
the project will be based on optical
fiber technologies so FTTH is really
starting to happen in Poland exactly yes
thanks to these projects this will be
especially backbone and distribution
networks we pave the way for last mile
projects in the new EU budgetary
perspective 2014-2020 and for this
perspective we are allocated another 1
billion euro and under the programme
digital Poland co-financed by European
funds and thanks to this project we are
going to to cover the area with the
population we want to bring the access
for almost 4 million poles thanks to
this project from the senior budgetary
perspective wow I now we've talking
about so the superfast broadband here
yes we speak
about the internet above 30 megabits per
second and additional ranking points
will be granted to the projects which
assure the internet over 100 megabit per
second sounds like Holland is the place
to be for broadband methyl Poland is
a good place for investors for telecom
operators for vendors of telecom
infrastructure and also for construction
companies they should use the
opportunities coming with this with this
with this public support for the telecom
sector in Poland well thank you very
much for joining us today thank you
Brian so a very interesting perspective
of their of where EU funding is making a
real difference to a country